our main story tonight concerns trains
in the 1800s the preferred method of
murdering damsels are nowadays
anti-depressants for middle-aged dads
trains aren't just a mode of
transportation they are beloved
children's characters in shows like
Thomas the Tank Engine except not that
one I'm talking about the British
original narrated by Ringo Star which is
much darker take this episode in which
Henry the Green Engine gets frightened
of the rain and won't come out of a
tunnel everyone begs him and then yells
at him Thomas even tries to physically
push him out and then finally the head
of the Railway steps in with a drastic
solution we shall take away your rails
he said and leave you here for always
and always and always they took up the
old rails and built a wall in front of
him so that Henry couldn't get out of
the tunnel
[Music]
anymore
yeah the British version of Thomas
didn't around and episod who
premise is stop complaining about work
or we'll throw you in your Forever hole
has got to be one of the most disturbing
episodes of children's TV ever right up
there with the episode of Blue's Clues
where blue reveals herself to be the
Zodiac Killer come on Steve the clues
were a handgun a zodiac symbol and an
issue of the San Francisco Chronicle
from 196 69 she basically wanted to get
caught and if you're thinking well
surely that was the midpoint of the
episode and Henry was eventually allowed
out so that there'd be a happy ending
with all his friends it wasn't this is
how it ends he wondered if he would ever
be allowed to pull trains
again but I think he deserved his
punishment didn't
[Music]
you
look there are Children's shows and then
there are British children's shows and
that is why I am and this is true like
this well we're going to be talking
about one kind of train in particular
tonight freight trains and let me just
say for the record this show is prot
train they are objectively good they're
fast they're loud and they make noises
like chuga chuga choo choo and ding ding
ding ding ding I love trains and freight
trains are essential we rely on them to
transport around 28% of the country's
Freight and while trucks also carry
Freight great distances and have some
pretty hit sounds of their own to
which trains are much better for the
environment as they only account for 2%
of us Transportation emissions but
unfortunately as we saw earlier this
year in East Palestine Ohio when freight
trains go off the rails they can cause
immense damage that crash incurred an
estimated cost of at least 800 $ 103
million in total damages and 80% of
residents surveyed say they've
experienced headaches rash coughs eye
irritation and diarrhea and about 40%
say they suffer from PTSD for while that
was a particularly nasty derailment the
truth is it shouldn't have been that
surprising last year there were more
than a thousand train deal rment in the
US that means an average of three per
day and while most occur in Rail Yards
and aren't major incidents the ones that
occur outside of them can cause a huge
mess the Flaming freight train Inferno
outside Phoenix Arizona derailing on a
bridge in Tempe a runaway train
derailing in the Mojave Desert causing a
mangled mess tonight new dash cam video
shows the moment a norol Southern Train
derailed in Springfield Ohio from
livecopter 3 an exclusive view with the
Union Pacific trained rail Min 33 cars
total 22 derailed a red substance was
spilled but officials have not confirmed
what it is look none of that is good but
the phrase a red substance was spilled
but officials have not confirmed what it
is is truly chilling it sounds less like
a legitimate news report and more like
the first draft of a Steven King novel
so train derailments happen a lot and
experts say the reason we haven't had
massive loss of life in this country as
a result is more luck than anything else
the railroads are going to keep flirting
with danger keep Flirting With Disaster
as long as people are getting rich I
don't want to say that we dodged a
bullet in East Palestine but the next
one may be in a major urban area
it may be in a downtown Chicago it may
be in a downtown New York City it is
terrifying to think a train disaster
like East Palestine could happen in New
York partly because I live here and
partly because New Yorkers are dealing
with enough dread and panic as it is we
are a Perpetual Terror Target we got the
country's first big wave of covid we had
a Biblical plague of lantern flies last
summer and there's an army of creepy
Elmos running rampant in Time Square we
don't have the anxiety bandwidth to also
worry about a giant Train full of Po
poison exploding in the middle of the
city so if freight trains have the power
to cause that much damage tonight let's
talk about them and let's start with the
fact that the freight rail industry used
to be heavily regulated but in the 1970s
after the interstate highway system came
along and rail shipping lost a lot of
business to trucking there was pressur
to deregulate the industry so that it
could compete and in 1980 a lot of the
controls that we'd had in place were
removed allowing for huge consolidation
of railroad companies to the point where
while there used to be over 100 class
one railroads in North America there are
now just six massive extremely powerful
companies and much of the oversight of
safety is left to the Federal Railroad
Administration which is a fairly weak
regulator and it's not just me saying
that a government report found that the
agency itself estimates its inspectors
have the ability to inspect less than 1%
of the railroad activities covered in
regulation and as a result railroads
themselves have the primary
responsibility for the safety of the
railroad system and and if history's
taught us anything that's not a good
formula for positive outcomes if
anything the formula is industry plus
deregulation minus government oversight
equals episode of Last Week Tonight and
guess what guys here we are although I
will give the fr8 some credit it does
produce some spectacular Railway safety
videos to show you what not to do around
train
tracks
shoot I think the car just died h
seriously this is not happening why did
we stop what happened are we stuck it's
fine we'll just we'll sit here for a
minute
and I will call
someone but what if there's a train
coming don't worry there's never a train
here and I'm sure we would hear when
coming from pretty far away what are you
doing it is hard to pick a favorite
reaction from the world's calmest or
dumbest mom there I think the car just
died when your car clearly died is an
obvious Hall of Famer but for my money
I'm going to go with the absolute blind
confidence of there's never a train here
a fact she cannot know and doesn't seem
to totally believe herself also and this
isn't hugely important but I will call
someone who exactly do you think you'd
call and how do you think that call
would go hi my car broke down on some
train tracks I'm in the car with my
children get out of the car and off the
tracks I'm pretty sure there's never a
train here really cuz trains generally
go where the tracks are put one of your
children on the phone are you going to
send someone to help me officer lady I'm
not even the police this is just a
number that you called get off the
tracks but back to the FR as I was
saying the problem is that they have
limited insight into what's actually
happening on the rails and not every
problem is as e easy to solve as taking
away This Woman's driver's license
forever as we learned in East Palestine
some trains haul hazardous materials and
the truth is neither the F nor anyone
else knows their there which is wild it
is crazy that the FAA knows about the
exact location of 5,000 planes in the
sky but the F can't tell you where most
trains are or what they contain in fact
in the New York area a while back people
got pretty alarmed when they learned
that volatile crude oil was being
transported right along the Hudson River
this is the the greatest threat to the
Hudson I've experienced in my entire
career these trains that run for almost
50 miles right next to the river
carrying highly explosive crude oil in
rail cars that were not designed for
this that sheer an impact 120 cars on
some of these trains 30,000 gallons of
fuel per car very volatile fuel when it
comes down to it each of these train
cars is like a rolling bomb it's true
and that is not unique to the Hudson
Rail Line trains that carry combustible
cargo are regular referred to by rail
workers as bomb trains which is
terrifying bomb train doesn't sound like
something that should ever be allowed on
a railway it sounds like the title of a
Jason Stan movie that's got 27% on
Rotten Tomatoes but rolling bomb is a
pretty accurate description just 22
train cars carrying liquefied natural
gas hold the equivalent blast energy of
the nuclear bomb dropped on Hiroshima
and there have been inces where train
cars full of crude oil have exploded in
populated areas in Canada in 201 13
there was an explosion in the area of
Lac megantic that killed 47 people and
left the town looking like this which
may not seem so alarming and you see
what that exact spot looked like before
the blast it's hard to tell but if you
look very closely you'll notice that the
town part of that town is gone and the
notion that profits might be getting
prioritized over safety is in keeping
with the larger Trend shaping the
freight rail industry because like many
big companies these giant Railway firms
have felt increasing pressure to squeeze
margins to please investors and that
brings us to the key Trend in Freight
rail over the past few decades Precision
scheduled railroading or PSR is the
brainchild of this man Hunter Harrison
seen here mid
colonoscopy until his death six years
ago Harrison worked as a CEO at four
major railroads and his philosophy PSR
has now taken over the entire industry
and it's about agressively pursuing
efficiency to that end railroads have
closed facilities retired locomotives
and rail cars and cut workers to lower
costs and all of that is the kind of
stuff that makes Wall Street idiots
extremely happy in fact here's one of
them now Hunter
Harrison the new darling of Wall Street
Harrison will Implement a strategy
that's known as Precision scheduled
railroading he's already changed routes
and schedules and the way the company
sorts long trains he actually Maps them
out in his own living room I'm not
kidding this guy's the real deal the guy
is the train Whisperer
cool you know a person is pretty awesome
if they get a ringing sound effect Laden
endorsement on an esteemed show like big
bucks word puke with Captain money clown
but it's true Hunter Harrison was the
type of guy who mapped train routes out
at home he was also the type of guy who
looked for even the smallest ways to cut
costs from tearing up unused tracks to
eliminating overnight stays for a train
Crews he even flew around in a corporate
jet with a tail number that read o59 his
aspirational operating ratio Pres
something that made him so happy he
smiled like
this but that efficiency for the
companies has come at tremendous cost to
everyone else and let's start with one
of the things that may be less obvious
because a key component of precision
scheduled railroading is running fewer
but much longer trains and I mean much
longer some trains now stretch nearly
three miles long and those longer trains
aren't just dangerous when they're
moving they can also be dangerous when
they're not trains frequently need to
stop to to allow other trains to pass or
to work on mechanical issues and tracks
were built to accommodate this with
sidings alongside the mainline where
trains can pull over the problem is
those sidings were built when trains
were much shorter and nowadays when they
are multiple miles long they can wind up
stretching back onto the main track and
possibly across roads blocking traffic
and that is one reason why this can
happen for some East End neighborhoods
this has become a way too unwelcome
soundtrack The Bells start traffic stops
this driver sleeps this guy climbs over
this one too another right under all of
it without a thought to the potentially
deadly consequences the wait just
becomes too long so how often does this
happen Lorenzo um just about every day
that's true in certain towns trains can
block traffic and for hours and it's not
that they can quickly get out of the way
by turning around trains are like Liam
Payne they really only work in One
Direction last year alone there were
more than 30 thousand reports of blocks
train crossings Across the Nation with
nearly a thousand blocks for more than a
day and that can mean people wind up
making risky decisions to get to work or
even to school it's the kind of moment
that takes your breath away a little
girl in a bright red coat tiny arms and
legs wiggling underneath a train car
that could move at any moment it's quiet
as she dusts herself off casually picks
up her book bag in a dropped water
bottle and Carries on that is tough to
watch but I guess it is kind of nice for
the younger generation to have an
immediate counter whenever their older
relatives complain about how they used
to walk to school in the snow oh was it
cold Grandpa did it get chilly I guess I
wasn't really thinking about the weather
when I was crawling under a train that
could crush my tiny arms and legs to get
to Home Room on time and while
that girl thankfully was okay others
haven't been pedestrians trying to cut
through trains have been disfigured
dismembered and killed after the train
suddenly started moving on top of which
block train crossings can also seriously
delay Emergency Services like fire
engines or ambulances as this Oklahoma
man knows all too well I think it's
going to take a major tragedy for the
railroad company to wake up and decide
that they're going to do something that
was about 6 and a half years ago Chad
bird complaining about these tracks near
their home and at the time sitting on
the only Crossing to get to their home I
think the major concern is if somebody's
injured trying to get an ambulance to
that side fast forward to early
September of 2020 Chad's premonitions
becoming reality his father Larry Jean
bird dying from a heart attack in
emergency vehicles were stuck behind a
train on those same tracks when
emergency crews arrived police asked the
conductor if it could be moved he said
no the lawsuit adding that he quote
closed the locomotive's window and would
not respond to any further questions
that is awful and while it is not the
most important thing are we all just
allowed to close our windows and not
talk to Cops
or is that only for train conductors
because if so I will buy one of those
stupid little hats tomorrow but also I
wouldn't call his prediction a
premonition there it was an easily
foreseeable consequence of poor policy
and that is not a one-off there have
been multiple similar stories of people
dying and houses burning down after
emergency vehicles were delayed at
Crossings but longer stopped trains are
just the beginning of the issues with
PSR there was also the issue of what the
Relentless drive for savings does to
workers even even as trains got longer
staffing has been cut to ridiculously
low levels just watch as a union leader
explains to a flabergasted news anchor
right after East Palestine just how low
these levels had become look if you add
uh more and more cars to these trains
you're introducing more and more points
of potential failure um and that's why
it's really alarming that the railroad
industry actually wants to cut back the
number of people operating on a train
from two as is the current standard to
one I'm sorry hold on are you saying
that as of now now a train with 150 cars
and that is carrying hazardous material
Vinyl chloride whatever as a standard
only only has two people operating it
just two for that entire
train yeah that's correct one conductor
one engineer and they want to cut it
down to one yes right one person which
is absurd trains need an engineer to
drive the train and a conductor for the
rest of it it's not one of those jobs
where we have two people do it even
though it clearly only requires one like
anchoring the news or renovating a home
or hosting the 2011 Oscars and and
people who work on these trains will
tell you every part of their job is
exhausting now for example when there
are mechanical or other problems that
cause a train to stop the conductor may
have to walk from the lead locomotive to
the problem area and back again which
could mean walking four miles to the end
and back on a 2m long train workers
being stretched so thin that they're now
working ridiculous hours and required to
be on call forcing them to pick and
choose between work and their families
and even medical appointments until
recently when workers wanted to take a
sick day at BNSF the largest freight
Railroad in the US they had to schedule
them a month in advance and only for
Tuesday Wednesday or Thursday and I
don't know how BNSF thinks illnesses
work but the flu doesn't have a
Microsoft Outlook calendar where you can
look at its schedule and book your
infection at a time that works for both
of you and while BNSF changed that
policy this fall it's still in effect at
other major railroads a former Union
head sums up the situation like this as
we say you either go to work uh sick and
tired or you get fired that's really the
what this has come down to look it is
never a good sign when conditions are so
Bleak you've come up with a catchy
little rhyme for it also no one should
get fired for being sick as far as
punishments go for not being able to
work one day it's right up there with
being inomed in the tunnel of constant
punishment and having sick tired workers
is bad across the board but it gets much
worse when you realize some of those
workers are the ones who inspect the
trains to keep them safe and the time
allotted for that keeps shrinking one
former Railroader says norfol Southern
inspectors used to have 5 to 8 minutes
to check a train car's wheels for
problems like leaky bearings or damaged
components now it's often between 30
seconds and a minute and worse still
employees feel that they can't speak out
as a result of a pattern of retaliation
against workers who report safety
violations or injuries one whistleblower
even sued his company and had some
pretty compelling evidence on his side
Don Sanders a former BNSF Track
Inspector in Minnesota secretly recorded
calls with his supervisor back in 2015
in this recording obtained by five
investigates you'll hear what happened
when the boss found out Sanders called
the Federal Railroad Administration why
in the world would we ever call about
anything unless I'm absolutely blatantly
telling you to break rules or don't do
something is that against the company
rules it's not good I call him and ask
him a question Keith I don't understand
I don't want you're doing that yeah that
is automatically suspicious if you work
at a restaurant and your boss tells you
that under no circumstances should you
ever call the health inspector best case
scenario he is being ratat toed but
that's the best case that inspector was
later fired in what a JY later agreed
was retaliation for reporting too many
track defects and another rail worker
sums it all up like this the railroad
probably 100 years ago came up with
safety first when Precision scheduled
railroading came out they gave us a list
of priorities that we were to work by
safety's fourth here's the thing that is
true safety is fourth he's not
embellishing there Hunter Harrison would
frequently run down a numbered list of
his guiding principles which started
with service then cost control then
asset utilization and then and only then
safety it was literally fourth on the
list and once you get past three items
on a priority list anything after that
isn't a priority by definition it's like
ranking your favorite Beatles there are
three that you care about and one
afterthought who narrate sadistic
children shows about abused
trains and at one hearing when Harrison
was running through his list and
eventually got two safety he wound up
making a pretty striking confession the
fourth portion of
this
is which we sometimes don't pay the
appropriate attention to is just simply
don't get anybody hurt while you're
doing this now we can be very
sophisticated and we can talk about risk
management and loss control and programs
and processes and so forth uh I got
blood all over my
hands uh from injuries in this industry
that should have been avoidable wow I've
got to say after 10 seasons of showing
you Executives deny their neglect that
is almost refreshing it's the kind of
honesty you only usually get from a guy
like that after he's being visited by
the ghosts of
Christmas and look Railway companies
will tell you that safety has always
been important to them and they'll point
out that derailments have fallen by 44%
since 2000 which is true although I'll
point out that some of that is because
we're running far fewer trains since
then also the rate of derailment for
large railroads has been creeping up
again in recent years one Railway
veteran describes a major crash as just
a matter of time fearing there's going
to be a freight train that hasn't been
inspected in 990,000 mies that comes off
the track and either explodes or leaks
poisonous gas out it's can take
something like that and a lot of deaths
and then all of a sudden everybody's
going to Care you've now heard that
exact sentiment multiple times in this
piece and he's probably right and look
the solution here isn't to turn away
from rail again trains are good because
for one they're still safer than
Trucking and two as we've already
established chuga chuga choo choo ding
ding ding trains are
fun but that doesn't mean they shouldn't
be safer and all that requires is some
very common sense measures regulating
the length of train cars allowing more
time for train inspections not letting
this woman near trains cars or children
properly Staffing trains with
appropriate sized Crews and carefully
limiting the amounts and roots of
hazardous materials being transported
now to ensure that happens we need to
empower the F to actually monitor trains
and Cargo in real time and while we're
at it given the ability to limit the
amount of time the trains can block
intersections and finally and crucially
workers need a way to confidentially
report safety issues to Regulators
without being afraid of retaliation
until we fix all of this we might really
need to fundamentally change our
children's programming to show the world
of trains as they currently
are Once Upon a Time on the island of
Sodor there was a train named Henry
Henry was a freight train and he pulled
all kinds of important materials
around but then one day s toam hat had
an idea and suddenly Henry got longer
and longer and longer
[Music]
Henry got so long when he rested he
started getting in people's way and
drivers got very angry with him I'm late
for work what's the hold up
train said the driver a little old lady
shouted to Henry get
a little girl crawled underneath
Henry on her way to
school that tickles said Henry I
hate you train said the little
girl a fire engine pleaded with him to
move I can't move said Henry I don't
have any room so they both just sat
there and watched the Children's
Hospital
Burn but Henry was told he was much more
efficient now which is another way of
saying profitable and 9 M long he
carried all sorts of things people
needed like medical bandages corn vinyl
chloride fireworks a mysterious red
substance question mark question mark
hand grenades question mark plugged in
space heaters and all sorts of zoo
animals what's liquefied natural gas and
why am I pulling 22 Cars full of it
Henry asked never you mind said s topam
hat i m this whole route out at home
that's a weird thing to do and I don't
really know how to respond to it said
Henry just mind your business like a
good little rolling death machine Sir
Topham hat said sorry I'm a what asked
Henry then one day a wheel on one of
Henry's tank cars started overheating
his engineer hadn't had a chance to
inspect it in
months Henry was getting worried it's
seems my Caboose is loose I can't drive
with a loose caboose Henry told the
driver but it was too late oh said
Henry Henry the Freight engine became
Henry the bomb
[Music]
train
oh well thought Henry it could be worse
at least my tankers didn't
explode meanwhile on the other side of
the
island oh dear said
Thomas the explosion obliterated a
significant part of the island of
Sodor
Henry was so sad Sir Topham had had
blood on his hands but he didn't care it
wasn't his blood and he could just wipe
it off with all his new money as for
Henry he was taken out of commission and
put in a tunnel but as trains can't die
he just had to suffer forever and ever
but I think he deserved his punishment
don't
you
that's our show thanks so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
[Applause]
[Music]
night